in November 2013 then president Victoria
nikovic at the last moment refused to
sign the so-called Association agreement
with the EU and set Ukraine on a course
towards Russia instead the decision
sparked protests across the country
fueled by growing discontent with the
ruling Elite what started out as a
simple but large-scale expression of
discontent would soon balloon to a
massive pro-european movement against
Russian influence and government
corruption the protest epicenter was
Independent Square in Kiev also known as
maida nezalesnosti where the name Maiden
Revolution came from the protests went
on for months until people say that
there's a sniper on a building
overlooking the Institute Sky Street
behind me
where bullets have gone through their
Shields
pretty sure which building the sniper is
in but so any of us here could get hit
we're here in front of the hotel you're
crying and that overlooks Independent
Square only when clashes began it
started being used as a triage center
for the wounded apparently inside there
are a number of dead bodies and mostly
from gunshot wounds on the 19th of
February 2014 police opened firearm
protesters with live ammunition killing
dozens how did we get here how does a
European country in the 21st century go
from pro-european protests to police
opening fire the answer can be found in
Ukraine's recent political history in
2004 Victoria won the presidential
election against this pro-european
opponent Victor ushenko the election was
considered massively fraudulent both
domestically and internationally having
been Rife with water intimidation voter
suppression and massive corruption this
resulted in the so-called orange
Revolution a peaceful protest movement
that was successful in the end having
achieved an election rerun there
yushenko beat janakovich by an 8 margin
and became president of Ukraine in the
next election however in 2010 yanukovic
made a comeback by a thin margin after
which he impressed in his main
pro-western opponent Julia jimoshenko
the trial was of course a complete force
kimoshenko was a political prisoner but
the election once again exposed the
massive divide inside Ukraine between
pro-western and pro-russian regions the
pro-western Heartland being the areas
around levit while the pro-russian the
areas around Donetsk the reason for the
party of Region's popularity was in
large part then favoring Devolution of
power to the regions and more autonomy
for minorities linguistic or ethnic now
the areas in the south and east are
mostly russian-speaking and are closer
to Russia culturally there is of course
nothing wrong with wanting to give
minorities more autonomy the problems
start when the Russian government uses
these minorities versus the Trojan Horse
and then a better Ingram in service of
the geopolitical interests and make no
mistake Russia was not going to let
Ukraine move towards the West they were
to remain firmly in Russian orbit and
Unico which was the guarantee for that
but alas there was a small problem most
people supported European integration
over moving towards Russia in the minds
of many ukrainians Russia represented
oppression poverty corruption and the
occasional genocide and thus during the
protest statues of Lenin became targets
as the perceived symbols of the Russian
World just like the King George statues
during the American war for independence
but the will of the people never stopped
the Russian or pro-russian government
from doing what they want anyway and so
Unico which held fast despite growing
discontent and his tactics to quell the
protests were rather colorful at one
point his prime minister started
fear-mongering about how the EU
Association agreement would mean that
Ukraine has to legalize same-sex
marriage which you know okay otherwise a
choice method of intimidation was the
use of so-called tituski these were
violent thugs in civilian clothing paid
by the government to do their dirty work
they blend into protests to instigate
violence beat up protesters and
occasionally murder journalists but this
and the increasingly brutal police
actions did little to calm the protests
in fact especially from the government
pounded people held together even more
firmly it was amazing to see how these
events galvanized Ukrainian Society
previously there was barely any national
Unity or cohesion only people
commiserating on the ruins of the Soviet
Empire but through the protests
ukrainians had shown unprecedented
willingness to cooperate and
self-organize it was this Bittersweet
moment when they had to make a stand
against their own government that was
only getting more violent as time went
on with the fates of the protesters
uncertain and kievabs with numerous
reports of activists being abducted we
headed to meet euromaidan SOS so we have
started this initiative on the 30th of
November we want to help with that legal
aid but unfortunately we started to do
almost everything your purpose is to
help any who might be any legal trouble
or if they've been injured or if they go
missing yes this is our Workshop making
Shields and some armor and what did you
do before the Revolution my job I am the
organizer of some events the protesters
energy however was not infinite by the
19th of February 2014 as the events
strike down for the third month the
protests briefly ran out of steam people
were exhausted and supplies were
depleted of course the government was
aware of this and so on the same day
they were about to launch their final
assault on the maidan they had to move
fast more protesters were on their way
to Kiev and risked giving the movement
new momentum here's how one of the
protesters described the moments before
the government Ambush at about five
o'clock in the morning the situation was
getting desperate our alliance had been
pushed back the barricades on produce
lion Street and on kreshatic were left
unmanned the others kept asking what we
should do when the barcode launches the
offensive we agreed that we would keep
fighting yes wives children and parents
are waiting for us all at home a man of
about 60 side but since we're here we
have to hold out till the end come what
may there is nothing worse than waiting
for danger to come and knowing you're
helpless against did the others started
calling their relatives I won't be able
to talk for long my fellow countrymen
said on the phone I'm all right don't
tell Marshall I called but if you can't
reach me in a few hours tell my wife I
love her very much I took out my phone
too my wife and three sons were waiting
for me at home I wanted to call them and
tell them something but there was a lump
in my throat it's starting our friend
vasia shouted suddenly they're coming
looks like tituske turning around I saw
100 people approaching with shields and
bats on our side there were no more than
20 of us left the men walked briskly and
confidently I was about to start
flinging stones at them when for some
reason the stranger stopped about 15
meters away from us they are with us I
heard Russia shout Brothers one of them
said we're sorry we took so long they
were the living hundred they told us how
the police tried to stop them from
reaching Kiev they were stopped several
times on the jitterman highway but they
were able to break through the police
lines and continue on the appearance of
the group that later came to be known as
The Living hundred was one of those
right place at the right time type
situations with their help the remaining
protesters managed to mend the
barricades in adequate numbers however
little did they know that the government
had at this point decided to change
strategy evident from the strange loud
bangs that could be heard shortly after
because of the smoke I couldn't see what
was happening suddenly a man fell down
at my feet I had already seen him
somewhere before must have left
Consciousness I thought and as I was
about to give him a slap to wake him I
saw a hole in his Temple blood seeped
from the wound the guy was shot a second
later another one fell nearby one of the
1100 shot dead dragging further
casualties into the hotel lobby I could
barely comprehend what was happening
everything was like a nightmare I will
forever remember a tall black-haired man
of about 60 entering the hotel I saw him
among the live hundred together with a
guy very similar to him they were father
and son they thought as they say
shoulder to shoulder but this time the
man came alone one by one he began to
lift the sheets that covered the dead
seeing the face of one of them he
stopped he knelt down and took off his
helmet hands trembling the doctors tried
to pull him aside but the men wouldn't
budge he just found the body of his son
in the end their sacrifice along with
everyone else's was not in vague the
murder of protesters was only fueled to
the fire and the movement rebounded with
new momentum following days of desperate
stalemate victorianukovych fled the
country assisted by Russian Spetsnaz the
revolutionaries won the portio regions
disbanded a caretaker government was
installed and a new presidential
election was scheduled for the 25th of
May with the president gone people found
his Villa deserted and unguarded words
spread like wildfire and soon enough
massive crowds started showing up to
behold the insane luxury and lavishness
of victorinocovich's now former
lifestyle
foreign
this is the main office of Yanukovych
wow pretty Grand
you guys are working for 200 Euros a
month and your president lives in a
place like this how does that make you
feel
you saw it yeah you're amazing people's
self-defense at some point will give
them to the state okay because it
belongs to people and we hope this will
be the first in the world Museum in the
museum museum of corruption and they
actually did the measure residence
Museum to this day is open for visitors
but the revolutionaries had little time
to celebrate their Victory on the 27th
of February unmarked heavily armed
soldiers began seizing government
buildings in Crimea they came to be
known as Little Green Men sporting
high-end Russia military gear on the 1st
of March pujin requested and received
official approval from himself basically
to deploy Russian troops to Ukraine that
was of course a formality since at that
point Crimea was effectively under a
complete Russian control two weeks later
a referendum was organized where people
could decide whether Crimea should
become part of Russia the two choices
were yes and yes and how did that happen
option number one was do you support
joining Crimea with the Russian
Federation as a subject of the Russian
Federation pretty straightforward
however option number two was the
following do you support the restoration
of the 1992 Crimean Constitution and
Crimea status as a part of Ukraine the
problem is the 1992 Constitution
declares Crimea as an independent state
so yeah we can all see what they did
there in the end it didn't matter much
since according to the results 95.5
percent voted for joining Russia with an
official term and out of 85 percent
however the real turnout was around 40
percent with 50 to 60 percent of people
voting for joining Russia how do we know
that because the Russian president's
Human Rights Council accidentally posted
the real statistics which they then
quickly deleted but not before people
took notice the propaganda surrounding
the referendum was part of the Russian
Narrative of heroic anti-fascism more on
that later the referendum was of course
a complete force and there was no
question where Crimea would end up
eventually it remains to this day under
Russian control in violation of the 1994
Budapest memorandum which Russia agreed
to stating among other things that
Russia cannot use Force against Ukraine
and has to respect its independence and
Sovereign borders Russian foreign
minister Sergey lavrov later lied about
this saying how the memorandum only said
not to attack Ukraine with nukes but
after literally five seconds of Googling
you can find that the memorandum
actually had six points half of which
Russia is openly violating but at that
point Russia didn't even pretend to care
about International agreements Crimea
was firmly in their hands boosting
Vladimir Putin's approval rating from a
historic low of 62 percent to a six-year
high of 85.9 percent but just as the
Crimean crisis came to an end a whole
new series of crises started emerging
pro-russian protests spread across the
east and south the largest ones in
donetska luhans their locations mostly
corresponded to areas where yonakovich
is now a former party had the most
support Pro Ukrainian counter protests
followed usually outnumbering the former
the epicenters of the pro-russian
movements were harkiv Odessa and luhans
directions had varying degrees of
success in harkiv protesters stormed the
city theater first after mistaking it
for City Hall afterwards they occupied
the regional state administration
building and proclaimed the horkie
People's Republic later that day
Ukrainian Special Forces kicked him out
of the building which marked the end of
the Republic and also the local protests
in Odessa pro-russian protesters didn't
actually want to become part of Russia
rather an autonomous region within
Ukraine clashes between pro-russians and
pro ukrainians culminated at the trade
Union's house where the letter group
encircled the former outnumbered the
pro-russians FED inside the building and
started through
from the roof the pro-ukrainian
protesters responded similarly with
Molotov cocktails long story short the
building caught fire killing 43 that was
more or less the end of the pro-russian
protest in the region Donetsk and luhans
query different story however there the
Russian influence was the strongest and
locals had legitimate grievances against
the previous Ukrainian governments these
are mostly under-investment funneling
money out of the region and so on
protesters and later armed insurgents
occupied most government buildings in
donetskan lujans quickly spreading West
to contain them on the 9th of April 2014
the so-called anti-terrorist operation
was launched by the Ukrainian government
however two major factors played against
them first off the Ukrainian Army was
incomplete shambles at the start of a
conflict they had around 3 000
deplorable troops with obsolete of the
non-existent gear they had to be propped
up by volunteers donations and foreign
aid the second problem was the locals
who were in the east in many cases
staunchly pro-russian there were many
cases of them simply blocking the
Ukrainian Army and forcing them to
surrender their weapons and equipment
with low morale and certain allegiances
many units complied other units often
composed of motivated volunteers were
actually pushing back against the
pro-russian insurgents this included
far-right alternationalist militias as
well to nobody's surprise at this point
fighting was concentrated around
government buildings inside cities as
the skirmishes continued a referendum
was held on the 11th of May in the
separatist control territories similar
to the one in Crimea if official results
are to be believed 89 percent voted for
seceding from Ukraine as a relevant side
note at that point the separatists were
led by Igor Gerkin a Russian veteran and
former FSB officer who a day after the
referendum declared himself supreme
commander of the donask People's
Republic he called for the destruction
of all Ukrainian military units in the
area and requested Russia military
intervention against the quote-unquote
impending NATO Invasion and genocide now
earlier I've mentioned the Russian
Narrative of separatists being heroic
anti-fascist Warriors this idea is a
Cornerstone of Russian propaganda
painting the Ukrainian government as
basically Nazis thus establishing some
half-pay parallel with Soviet troops
fighting actual not is during World War
II over here in reality though things
are a bit different of course
pro-ukrainian far-right elements were
also present during the revolution such
as the right sector however at no point
were they in control of the country and
they remain on the fringes to this day
on top of that Ukraine's current
President Vladimir zelenski who won a
landslide victory in 2019 is a Russian
native speaker and Jewish so it's not
exactly the fourth Reich over there to
the Russians worried about the Ukrainian
Nazis I can tell the same thing I would
tell Americans worried about islamists
if you don't want to risk extremist
skating power and prominence don't
invade their countries that tends to
Galvanize them but how does this Russia
the brave anti-fascist Warrior narrative
hold up to scrutiny oh boy here's puchid
in 2018 in Austria dropping by the
wedding of the far-ride FPU party's
foreign minister Karen knisl this whole
event was just bizarre to say the least
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the former Chief of the Fall Right party
who was forced to resign in 2019 due to
the so-called Ibiza Scandal where he
promised the supposed needs of a Russian
oligarch lucrative construction projects
in exchange the Russians were to take
over cronen's item Austria's biggest
newspaper a major force in swaying
voters and turn it into a pro FBO outlet
but the oligarchs quote-unquote nice
turned out to be an undercover
journalist and the whole conversation
was recorded also here's Heinz Christian
stalker in 2009 protesting the opening
of an Islamic Cultural Center in Vienna
I'm sorry this photo was just too far
enough to include in France Marine Le
Pen's for right party was financed by a
Russian Bank also here she is in 2017
having been invited to the Kremlin by
Putin where she talked about the need
for friendship and cooperation with
Russia and how sanctions are the answer
and so on and here's her exam War
France's new far-right figurehead
recently found guilty of inciting hatred
and racial abuse having called
unaccompanied migrant children thieves
murderers and rapists about Putin here
this to say Putin has restored the state
stepped in as the last under of the
Christians of the East he exalts the
Russian character of the country defends
National sovereignty the family and the
Orthodox religion zamboo's presidential
bid now has Russian backing by the way
how about the German far-right party the
eye of day yep they're getting
invitations to Moscow aside from other
worrying connections and let's not
forget about Victor Orban one of the
most pro-russian politicians in the EU
now I don't mean to sound negative or
anything but Urban is an
ethno-nationalist and he kind of made
the Jewish question part of his campaign
in the form of a billboard campaign
against the so-called shorosh plan which
according to Orban is a plan by George
harosh and his shadowy Elite to flood
Europe with brown people thus committing
white genocide this line of rhetoric is
not alien to our friends at Russia today
either I could go on for a while about
other far-right parties in Europe and
all their ties to Russia but then this
video would be 12 hours long but you get
the point why does heroic anti-fascist
Russia seem to have such bizarre
connections to virtually every European
far-right movement it's almost like this
modern version anti-fascism is complete
[__] almost but back to Ukraine this
really clear politics article details
all the separatist figureheads murky
ties to a number of Russian far-right
movements I suggest you give it a read
it's very eye-opening my favorite part
of the article is this while the
infamous donates leaflet ordering juice
to register and pay a special fee to the
separatist government was almost
certainly a hoax Russian political
scientist Anton chekovsov points out
that there have been real and numerous
manifestations of anti-Semitism in the
anti-midan movement in Southeastern
Ukraine among them Street posters
internet posts and even speeches at
rallies attacking the new key of
government as a Jewish Clique seeking to
use ukrainians to defend the interest of
wealthy Jews or depicting the modern
Revolution as a Zionist coup the
euro-asian Jewish Congress notes that
when pro-russian separatists seize
control of the television station in
slavians go on April 17th their
introductory broadcast was a video
wearing the logo and web address of the
rapidly anti-semitic popular Liberation
movement and promising that their
broadcasting would be a counter-attack
against the quote-unquote Zionist zombie
box the article also talks about the
Russian Kozak militiamen who fought with
the separatists whose goal according to
one of its leaders is to destroy the Jew
Masons who are fermenting disorder all
over the world and causing us the common
Orthodox Christian folk to suffer the
article goes on another Kozak in
slaviansk told the Guardians Luke
Harding that Russians and ukrainians
were one people before Jews Like Trotsky
divided us and the reason why all these
far-right weirdos have such a presence
among separatists is because
fundamentally both Crimea and the
donbest are nationalistic projects
aiming to restore some mythical past
greatness of Russia you know Umberto Eco
style at this point we need to talk a
bit about Russia's geopolitical goals
and plans going into the Ukrainian
conflict the goal was simple to keep
Ukraine firmly in Russian orbit is a
geopolitically important buffer state
plan a was to keep yanukovic in power
thus cementing Russian influence for
good that of course didn't work the
protests were much more intense than
anyone had expected Plan B was to fuel
the pro-russian protest movements after
maidan led the country collapse into
chaos and then simply take over but that
didn't work either because because of
what the maiden produced which pushing
would never have expected the Revival of
a Ukrainian national identity that held
most of the country together plan C was
then to escalate the conflict into an
armed Insurgency and take over the
russian-speaking east and south of the
country I.E the novorossia project and
we'll find out how that worked out in
the first days and weeks of the war
fighting was concentrated inside cities
in the donetskandluhan's regions on the
9th of May 2014 a group of armed
separatists tried capturing the modiopol
Police Department police resisted but
were eventually overwhelmed by Superior
Firepower leaving six of them dead the
police station was burned down in the
end the separatists managed to get a
shaky hold on the city for about a month
when on the 14th of June the city was
recaptured by Ukrainian forces they were
aided by right sector and other
volunteers both far-right Ultra
nationalist groupings the letter used
armored vehicles created from dump
trucks using them as mobile firing
positions against the separatists once
the Ukrainian Army blasted into the city
the six hour operation began in which
modiopo was effectively retaken and was
made the temporary capital of the
Donetsk region this Victory turned out
to be crucial later on since Mario Paul
is a strategically important city for
multiple reasons it has one of the
biggest steel plants in Europe and
blocks the way for a land bridge
connecting Russia with Crimea as the
conflict dragged on the Ukrainian Army
slowly reorganized itself into an at
least workable military which started
showing results the biggest Factor here
was the Ukrainian Air Force which
managed to inflict heavy losses on the
separatists who were at this point a
bunch of loosely organized armed groups
with nowhere defense the separatist held
areas were shrinking rapidly it really
looked like it's just a matter of time
until the Insurgency was over seeing
this Russia decided to supply the
separatists with some heavy entire
weapons to counter the Ukrainian Air
Force but then something happened on the
17th of July 2014 separatists succeeded
in shooting down a plane above donbass
using a Sam missile launcher do we
remember Igor girkin from earlier former
FSB Supreme Commander right after the
plane went down he made a post on
viconductor that's Russian Facebook
gloating about it his post reads
approximately as follows we've just shot
down an an-26 into area it fell
somewhere around the progress mine we've
worn them already do not fly in our
skies here's video proof of the bird's
descent the bird crashed past the mine's
dump and didn't damage residential areas
no civilians were hurt there is
information about a second downplay most
likely Sukhoi so that's pretty
straightforward separatists managed to
shoot down a military plane and now
their leader is on social media gloating
about it however upon inspecting the
wreckage they made a startling discovery
foreign foreign
YouTube
[Music]
videos
on the 17th of July 2014 Malaysia
airlines mh17 flying from Amsterdam to
Kuala Lumpur with 293 people on board
was shot down over the donbass there
were no survivors all non-russian
investigations came to the same
conclusion the plane was shot down by
separatists by mistake using a book
missile launcher belonging to the 53rd
air defense Brigade of the Russian army
from near the city of Kursk bellingcat
did a great investigation on this using
open sources where they reconstructed
the book's route based on photos and
geolocation including it being smuggled
back to Russia on a trailer on the 18th
of July I highly recommend you read
through the report it's very interesting
Link in the description to reiterate
separatists shot down a civilian plane
over the donbass with a Russian anti-air
system killing almost 300 civilians and
then both Russia and the separatists
admitted their fault and by that I mean
they deny everything to this day despite
having been proven wrong beyond the
shadow of a doubt okay we need to talk
about the Russian response to the
Downing of mh17 because Jesus Christ
let's just let's just get into this
let's consider this article together
Russian TV airs 2 clearly fake image to
claim Ukraine shutdown image 17 by
busway news on Friday Russia's Channel 1
published what it said were satellite
photos proving that a Ukrainian
government fighter jet shot down
Malaysia Airlines flight 17 in July host
Michael who is also a vice president of
the state of a giant roznavt said that
the pictures were sent to the Russian
Union of Engineers by an MIT graduate
named George Bild language have quoted
an email from build in which he said
that the plane quote was shut down with
a classic jet fighter attack from the
rear semi sphere end of quote according
to Russian propaganda at the time mh-17
was shot down by a Ukrainian su-25 the
article goes on Russian bloggers however
quickly took the claim to Pieces
photographer rustam atagamov found that
part of the image came from the Google
Images cache dating back to August 2012.
journalist Sergey porcomenko found
several other pictures taken from
yandex.maps a Russian site also the
fighter plane on the photo published by
the Russians doesn't look like a su-25
it looks more like a su-27 or MiG-29
here it is this is the soon-25 looks
nothing like the plane on the pitch also
the Boeing in the picture turned out to
Bear a suspicious resemblance to the
first Russian language Google Images
result for Boeing View from Above It had
the Malaysia Airlines logo in the wrong
place which turned out to be the Boeing
logo the distance was wrong the time was
wrong and the Russian Union of Engineers
turned out to not add up either even
andreevsky the quote-unquote expert
quoted in the show does not appear to
have an engineering education a quick
analysis of his PhD turned up obvious
signs of plagiarism and by the way the
su-25 cannot even reach the altitude of
Passenger flights its Max attitude
clocking in at about 7 kilometers how
did the Russians deal with this
discrepancy they doubled down on the
claim to the point where people from
moscow-based IP addresses edited the
su-25's maximum altitude on its
Wikipedia page from 7 kilometers to 10.
now I went back and found the actual
edit it's still in the history this is
from Russian Wikipedia by the way I've
translated the page in Chrome according
to sources even the base model reaches
10 000 meters this edit was made three
days after the mh-17 disaster right so
as we've discussed they this is a lie
and the sources linked there are either
irrelevant or don't provide any data
about past edits so there's that but
wait there's more there was an update to
the BuzzFeed article which reads as
follows how could we check it a Russian
quote-unquote expert said when
confronted with glaring mistakes in the
image it came to us from the internet
update the original source for the image
told BuzzFeed news that he found it
online and never expected to see it on
Russian TV quote those guys are either
desperate or totally unprofessional end
of quote so let's see Russian version of
events I suppose now you might be asking
what were they thinking whom were they
trying to convince with these fake
claims and Wikipedia edits well that's
just a thing they weren't trying to
convince you they were trying to make
you doubt everyone else the images they
published were complete debunked to
every person even remotely familiar with
image manipulation and military attack
but well most people aren't every
undiscerning journalist publishing the
images without thinking every mindless
share on social media every person even
talking about this really helps generate
more confusion more informational white
noise in it you're no longer sure what
the truth is meaning you're no longer
sure whether the Russian narrative is
false or not this was the first
large-scale instance of Next Generation
Russian information Warfare where the
goal isn't to convince but to sow the
seeds of Doubt so about that Wikipedia
edit where the su-25's altitude was
changed from 7 to 10 kilometers here's
how RT uses that proven falsification to
generate even more confusion Peter
heisenker is a German pilot with a long
service record he became interested in
the story of the downed Boeing after
seeing a photograph taken at the crash
site several days later a Russian
Ministry of Defense representative
published data showing that not long
before the tragedy another aircraft had
been observed in the vicinity of the
Malaysian Boeing reporting a Ukrainian
jet in the sky is
foreign
this is what next Generation propaganda
looks like the past is alterable the
past never had been altered the maximum
altitude is 10 kilometers the maximum
altitude had always been 10 kilometers
and even if this narrative is proven
wrong that's just one more sound in the
overwhelming informational white noise
in either case Russia wins it's both
genius and absolutely terrifying really
outside of this bizarre parallel
universe there was another version about
the tragedy by the Ukrainian Security
Service about how the real Target wasn't
mh-17 but a Russian plane to use as a
Kansas Valley for an invasion but that
claim was debunked by baling cat in the
end the real reason behind the Downing
of mh17 was simple incompetence by
separatists mistaking a civilian plane
for a military one around the time of
the mh-17 disaster the Ukrainian
military started making serious progress
during the so-called great rate of 2014
they beat back the separatists to the
point where they managed to cut off
dunya's kaluance from each other the
enemy was weakened the demoralized and
retreating in most theaters victory was
at Hand by mid-august Ukrainian troops
were inside donask advancing block by
block under pressure from Russia Igor
Gerkin resigned from the post of
separatist Commander he was replaced by
Alexander zakarchenko this represented
the Russian government's change of
strategy instead of Insurgency and
separatism the name of the game became
federalization I.E put pressure on the
Ukrainian government through the
conflict so they'll agree to federalize
the country which would result in Russia
being able to maintain its influence
over Ukraine to this end Russian troops
and Equipment started flowing into the
dumbass through the uncontrolled
checkpoints the little green men were
back this time making an appearance in
the East Ukrainian troops caught 10
Russian Peter Troopers in fact who
claimed they simply got lost around the
border the problem was they were caught
around the village of zarkale which is
about eight hours on foot from the
Russian border so either these
professional soldiers trained in
navigation couldn't Orient themselves
during 8 hours of marching or Russia was
deploying its troops inside Ukraine
after the separatists started losing
this Reuters article goes on to say two
witnesses told Reuters and Tuesday that
the dozens of men who arrived at the
weekend and set up a roadblock were not
local and had military Russian packs
marked with Russian writing while they
bore no Insignia their appearance or
behavior bore striking similarities to a
group of Russian troops detained in
Ukraine in the past few days and to
Russian forces which occupied Crimea
earlier this year the witnesses said so
yeah Russia started pushing troops and
Equipment across the border to prop up
the separatists an enormous
counter-attack followed where Russian
forces took large swords of the
donetskaluance regions suddenly the
Ukrainian Army found itself retreating
following the Russian Blitzkrieg a
ceasefire was announced in the form of
the so-called Minsk agreement this
specified Ukrainian and separatist lines
set up a buffer zone between the two and
banned artillery above 100 millimeters
despite this most of the fighting
continued also separatists held an
election on the 2nd of November in
violation of the agreement 331 people
died during the ceasefire which lasted
more or less until January 2015. the
following month however turned out to be
the darkest most brutal periods of the
donbass war in the morning of the 25th
of January 2015 without warning
separatists fired on mariopol with
so-called grad multiple rocket launchers
if you ever wondered what that looks
like from up close here we go
[Music]
the bombardment of Mario Paul left 27
dead the vast majority civilians
including two children no wonder the
Rockets were fired directly at a
residential area but what is grad
exactly I let our friends over at Russia
Today demonstrate
that's 13 Grand missiles that were just
fired at the Ukrainian Army Belen cat
later confirmed what everyone already
suspected the shelling was directed by
Russian officers and militants based on
their trajectory estimates the Rockets
clearly came from separatist control
territories I've linked their full
report in the description feel free to
go over it this of course was a war
crime and it wasn't the last but
parallel to the bombardment of Mario
Paul there was another series of events
unfolding following the Russian counter
attack ukrainians still held the city of
De Baltimore driving a wedge between the
two separatist territories it was a
strategically important Road in Railway
Crossing naturally the Ukrainian
defenses were significant separatists in
Lucifer formations had no realistic
chance of taking the city this brings us
to selfie soldiers an accident
documentary by Vice Linked In the
description the battle for the Strategic
town of De Baltimore and Eastern Ukraine
last February was a crucial turning
point in the war between Ukrainian
government forces and armed groups
backed by Russia reports started
surfacing that it was regular Russian
army units that made the victory
possible journalists recorded footage
showing soldiers of non-european
appearance who could not have come from
Ukraine operating heavy equipment and
even playing soccer near De Baltimore
looking into the background of a fighter
named Bato Dan bayev an ethnic Buria
from Siberia whose unit on the Mongolian
border was said to have been sent to
fight into balsava in eastern Ukraine a
picture of himself in his Russian army
uniform and here he is taking yet
another selfie with a Russian flag patch
on his arm this was posted on the 20th
of January
is
this is the exact spot where an ethnic
asian-looking Soldier had his selfie
taken in mid-February he then put that
photograph up on a Russian social
networking site and that's why we know
that he's a serving officer in the
Russian federation's army despite
mountains of evidence Russia denies any
involvement in the Ukrainian conflict
viewing it as a domestic Ukrainian
matter while at the same time
threatening Ukraine with military action
should they launch an offensive against
the separatists at the time of the
battle of the Baltimore the Minsk
ceasefire agreement had already
collapsed after separatists launched an
offensive to retake Donetsk airport then
on the 12th of February Minsk 2 was
enacted A Renewed peace agreement
calling for complete and unconditional
ceasefire among other things it was
agreed to by all sides but then the
separatists stated that it doesn't apply
to the Baltimore so they launched the
aforementioned defensive pushing the
Ukrainian military out of the city a
week later to Russia and its allies
Agreements are just words in a paper at
this point after the Baltimore the
ceasefire was observed until separatists
launched yet another and save against
the town of marinka involving tanks and
artillery on the 3rd of June
interestingly this resulted in the first
anti-war protest in Donetsk where 500
people blocked the road in front of the
administration building calling for the
fighting to stop after the marinko
offensive fighting died down they don't
best war became a frozen conflict with
only occasional skirmishes along the
front lines 2016 turned out to be a
relatively peaceful year during which
only about 500 Ukrainian soldiers died
the ceasefire agreement was holding
until separatists launched an offensive
on the city of abdifka on the 29th of
January 2017. then on the 18th of
February Russian foreign minister Sergey
lavrov announced a new ceasefire
agreement funny how Russia is always at
the negotiating table for this domestic
Ukrainian conflict that Russia has
nothing to do with but this ceasefire
agreement was kind of observed in the
end the fighting never stopped but its
intensity was much lower in 2020 only 50
Ukrainian soldiers died in battle and in
2021 only 25 that's a 50 reduction in
combat but that's in a democratic
country's military fighting against the
proxies of its larger neighbor engaged
in a war of territorial Conquest in 2021
Europe but even during the war life
didn't stop in the rest of the country
the 2014 election saw pro-ukrainian
parties winning a landslide as for the
Ukrainian fall right there were two such
parties right sector and svoboda the
right sector won a Single Seed while
disobeda party lost 31 seats some people
would count the radical party the rpol
S4 ride but they're more libertarian
leading thread counts with a slight
center-left bend a pro-russian party
also ran in the elections the so-called
opposition block a merger of six
anti-midan parties including former
partier regions MPS winning 27 seats one
of their leading politicians in
Parliament was Victor medvechuk local
oligarch notable for his daughter's
Godfather being Vladimir Putin I'm not
joking meant that joke is considered an
ally and close friend of Putin and has
worked since 2014 to undermine Ukraine's
pro-european course he did this through
his media empire being the de facto
owner of three major Ukrainian TV
channels 112 Ukraine news 1 and 6 which
were used to spread Russian narratives
this article goes into detail about how
exactly this happened feel free to look
it up the 2014 presidential election was
won by pro-european Pedro poroshenko by
a wide margin from that point on Ukraine
started its movement towards the EU the
law on decommunization was enacted
aiming to remove all Soviet monuments
from public spaces changed Soviet era
names of public spaces and ban all
totalitarian symbols including Soviet
and Nazi ones according to official
statistics more than 51 000 streets and
about a thousand settlements were
renamed while 1320 Lenin statues and
1069 others were removed some people got
creative though in Odessa Lenin was
turned into Darth Vader so they won't
have to bother with removal the red
stars were replaced by the Ukrainian
Trident while statues and monuments were
taken to museums signaling the end of an
era decentralization reform was enacted
not the kind Russia wanted where Donetsk
and lujans have a veto in foreign policy
but a process of strengthening local
governance giving local communities more
sources of funding and eliminating the
top heavy the over centralized Soviet
structural government the Ukrainian
Orthodox Church used as a geopolitical
tool by Russia was allowed to officially
secede from the Moscow patriarchate
negating Russian influence on
churchgoers vitaliklitschko former
Ukrainian boxing champion became the
mayor of Kiev so there's that Ukraine
received a Visa waiver meaning
ukrainians could now travel to the EU
without having to get a Visa due to
reforms and improving governance the
economy grew despite the war poroshen
could drink his presidency requested
NATO membership multiple times but
nobody in the alliance dead risking such
a thing I want you to consider this in
light of recent developments by the way
corruption remained an issue though so
in the 2019 presidential election
poroshenko did not get a second term a
former actor and comedian volodmir
zelenski won the presidency in a
landslide Victory campaigning on
anti-corruption and putting an end to
the donvess war with his candidacy the
traditional East-West divide disappeared
as an anti-corruption pro-piece Centrist
his appeal was Universal and this became
a significant problem for the Russian
propaganda machine according to their
narrative Ukraine is ruled by a all
right Western puppet government that
wants to eliminate Russian culture but
then Ukrainian like same
russian-speaking Jewish president in a
landslide who runs on a platform of
peace and Reconciliation on top of that
in the Parliamentary elections a few
months later fall right parties won a
single seat out of 450. zelenski's party
servant of the people also won in a
landslide gaining 254 seats the second
largest party became the pro-russian
opposition platform with 43 seats
chaired by the aforementioned Victor
madwachuk oopsy with the election of
zelenski and his party the pace over
forums accelerated significantly the
Army reform and re-equipment initiated
by poroshenko was continued resulting in
a far more capable military with 405 000
active personnel and 250 000 in reserve
their re-equipment has been underway for
a while now including with Hardware from
allies such as Humvees and javelins the
latter was a pretty big deal by the way
the reforms momentum also allowed for
some unique development with Estonian
assistance they stayed in a smartphone
project was launched so now as a
Ukrainian you can handle most government
bureaucracy through your smartphone
instead of having to go to some office
every time many cities created so-called
annual public budgets where people can
propose small local projects to
implement and then people can vote which
projects should get financing all in all
Ukraine is a country with huge potential
much of their industry survives to this
day including rocketry Aviation and
military hardware moreover 25 of all the
black soil on the planet is located
within the country which is the most
fertile type of soil that we know of
with land reform having been enacted in
mid-2021 projections point to Ukraine
becoming an agricultural superpower it
won't be that big a belief though since
they are already among the largest
exporters otherwise the image of
decaying buildings and broken roads
under a gray sky is slowly fading away
the road sector went through a complete
reform in 2019 so by 2021 they've
managed to repair 5098 kilometers of
roads in one year and looking at some of
these before after pictures well I
understand their motivation in part with
European and American financial
assistance a program for energy
modernization is underway both for
public and private buildings this is
both for the environment and for being
less dependent on Russian gas new norms
for urban planning have been adopted
replacing outdated Soviet standards the
first pedestrianization projects are
underway in Kiev while cities like live
are already ahead of the curve the rail
sector is next in line for reforms you
thought I won't find a way to talk about
trains huh because turns out Ukraine
also has a large Rolling Stock
manufacturing capacity the First new
domestically made passenger cars and
Diesel multiple units are already in
passenger service with more to come in
the near future the key of City Express
project was launched or I should say
relaunched which includes overhauling
Rolling Stock and building new Suburban
Rail lines also following the crisis in
Belarus Stadler is now looking to move
its Factory to Ukraine as you can see
things are mostly going in the right
direction stuff is getting done
Ukrainian democracy though very young
actually functions there are working
anti-corruption institutions so all in
all there is a reason for hope
Russian President Vladimir Putin
amassing troops in military hardware
near Ukraine's borders and could launch
an attack on the country at any time
Russia has for weeks been massing troops
and tanks along the Ukrainian border
Russia's massive buildup of troops and
Firepower on Ukraine's doorstep the
first of thousands of U.S troops have
now arrived in Poland and Germany to
support NATO and made amid fears of a
Russian invasion of Ukraine
[Music]